george floyd's death sparked protest
around the world but 10 months on the
anger
has turned to apprehension will change
and justice come
as the criminal trial begins the civil
lawsuit concludes
with a record payout from the city of
minneapolis
to the floyd family the settlement
is not just historic because
of the 27 million dollars
paid out but for the impact
on social justice policy reforms
and police reforms the next chapter in
their fight for justice
is here former officer derek shoven is
on trial for murder
in the fortified courthouse but there's
a deep mistrust among
some not just for police but for the
system
already critical the jury selection is
too white
and concerned a payout isn't justice
without a conviction
so it really is a significant settlement
and it's a
significant indictment of the way that
police have treated african-american
people in this country for a very long
time
so i you know for that standpoint it's
significant
but um beyond that we really do have to
have
a conviction in the case of derek
chauvin we really need that because
otherwise
the only people who will have had a
consequence
for this killing will be george floyd
himself and the taxpayers
how confident are you that you will get
that conviction
frankly i'm concerned exactly a year on
the family of brianna taylor
still don't feel they have justice shot
dead
in a flawed police raid of her home in
louisville
her family received a payout but no
accountability for her killing
their deaths may have been a reckoning
for racial inequity
but for many only a conviction will feel
like
change sally lockwood sky news new york